♪ ♪
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
ALSO NAMED IN THIS IT IS MY NEXT
GUEST, ALABAMA CONGRESSMAN MEL
BROOKS WHO SAYS HE HAS BEEN
M.I.A. FOR MONTHS.
HE EVEN HIRED A PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR TO FIND HIM.
THIS CAME TO A HEAD WHEN HIS
WIFE WAS ACCOSTED.
NOW LOOK AT THIS VIDEO,
CONGRESSMAN'S WIFE PULLS INTO
THEIR GARAGE, SECONDS LATER A
CAR SPEEDS UP THE DRIVEWAY.
A MAN JUMPS OUT AND RUNS INTO
THAT SAME GARAGE, ATTACHED TO
THEIR PRIVATE HOME.
THE MAN WAS IN THERE FOR ABOUT
15 SECONDS AND TELL BROOKS HIS
WIFE CHASED HIM OUT.
WE NOW KNOW THE HE WAS A PROCESS
SERVER.
CONGRESSMAN, YOUR MESSAGE
TONIGHT TO ERIC SWALWELL.
HE SAID HE WANTED TO SERVE YOU
AND YOUR WIFE, OR YOU COME AND
YOUR WIFE ACCEPTED ON YOUR
BEHALF.
BUT THAT IS JUST WHAT AN
AGGRESSIVE PROCESS SERVER DOES.
>> I'M A LITTLE BIT BAFFLED BY
ERIC SWALWELL'S CONDUCT IN A
VARIETY OF RESPECTS, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, THIS IS A FRIVOLOUS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED LAWSUIT.
THERE IS NO LIABILITY ON THE
PART OF MYSELF OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, ALTHOUGH I
PROBABLY STAND WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS WE DEFEND
THIS FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION.
BUT SECOND, FOR THREE MONTHS --
TWO MONTHS, SINCE THE LAWSUIT
WAS FILED BACK IN MARCH, ERIC
SWALWELL HAS GOT NOTICE OF WHEN
WE ARE GOING TO GO FOLK.
ROUGHLY 100 DIFFERENT TIMES HE
COULD HAVE HAD ME SERVED AS I'M
WALKING TO OR FROM THE CAPITAL,
THE HOUSE FLOOR WHERE I VOTE,
AND MY HOUSE OFFICE BUILDING.
BUT HE CHOSE NOT TO.
INSTEAD, THEY CHOSE TO HIRE A
PROCESS SERVER THAT WOULD CHASE
MY WIFE DOWN AS SHE'S COMING
HOME FROM CHURCH, KEEPING IN
MIND THAT SHE'S A GRANDMOTHER
WITH TEN GRANDCHILDREN PIT THAT
COULD'VE BEEN SOME OF THOSE
GRANDCHILDREN IN THE CAR WITH
HER WHEN THIS TRANSPIRED.
AND THEN ILLEGALLY ENTERED MY
HOME.
IN ALABAMA, THIS IS A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE -- IT'S TRESPASSING IN
THE FIRST DEGREE.
AND IT CARRIES A PENALTY UP TO
ONE YEAR AND A $6,000 FINE.
SO THEY DID IT ENTIRELY THE
WRONG WAY.
SERVED ME IN A NUMBER OF
VOCATIONS IN WASHINGTON WHEN
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY, BUT
INSTEAD THEY TOOK THE DISORDER
DISHONORABLE PATH.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT YOU NOT WANTING TO BE
A PART OF THIS LAWSUIT.
>> MEL BOOKS AT A LOT TO SAY
WHEN WHO ARE STANDING IN FRONT
OF A PRO-TRUMP CROWD TO
STORM THE CAPITAL, AND WHEN IT
BECAME CLEAR THAT THERE WERE
LEGAL CONSEQUENT IS FOR DOING
THAT, HE WASN'T INTERESTED IN
BEING A PART OF IT.
>> WAS THAT YOUR MESSAGE ON
JANUARY 6TH?
DID YOU INCITE A RIOT AT THE
CAPITAL?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WITH RESPECT TO ERIC SWALWELL,
LET ME EMPHASIZE THE SPIRIT I'VE
GONE THROUGH THE COMPLAINTS.
THERE ARE AT LEAST 50 OCCASIONS
IDENTIFIED, I'M SURE THERE'S A
LOT MORE, THAT I READILY
IDENTIFIED AS FLAT OUT LIES.
THEY ARE DECEIT, AND THESE
ALLEGATIONS -- THERE'S GOING TO
BE ZERO EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT IT,
MUCH LIKE THERE WAS ZERO
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THE TWO
YEARS OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION
ALLEGATIONS BY ERIC SWALWELL AND
OTHERS.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
IN WASHINGTON,